[Music]
the Nintendo switch had an incredible
first year selling faster than any video
game console in the history of mankind
but that doesn't mean it was all smooth
sailing so we're gonna be looking back
at some of the areas where Nintendo
missed the mark with the switch and also
where they could improve the system
don't get me wrong I think the switch is
awesome but we all know that it could
use a little more love in some spots now
keep in mind we'll have videos all this
weekend celebrating the switches first
anniversary so watch out for those on
GameSpot calm I've got a video talking
about the Wii U games that would be
perfect on the switch so make sure to
check that out too all right let's see
we're Nintendo done goofed this time the
switch launched worldwide on March 3rd
2017 and within the first couple of
weeks users started experiencing
connection problems with the left joique
on the controller would desync itself
from the system when used wirelessly
forcing people to either play in
handheld mode or with a pro controller
although Nintendo acted swiftly to
repair people's controllers it was still
an unfortunate roadblock for some users
leaving them unable to play a breath of
the wild the way they wanted but while
that issue was quickly addressed some
others still remain for example the
switch launched without any voice chat
options whatsoever which meant online
multiplayer games such as Mario Kart 8
and splatoon two would lack the usual
online gaming banter or handicap players
looking to coordinate with their
teammates Nintendo eventually offered a
solution to the problem except it was
one that nobody really asked for people
would have to use the Nintendo switch
phone app to connect with their friends
and if they wanted to hear the game
audio at the same time hook it up to a
third-party dongle plug that into the
system and their headphones to allow the
sound to pass through it's maybe the
least graceful solution that Nintendo
could come up with today there still
isn't any integrated voice chat insight
but that's not a huge loss compared to
what you could lose thanks to the
switches lack of cloud saves cloud saves
have been on many fans wishlist for
years and Nintendo still has not
provided us with a cloud-based save or
User Profile system that means
everything is tied to just one console
leaving many people out in the cold
should they lose their swish or have a
break which is an entire
we believable scenario for a portable
system perhaps Nintendo is preparing to
implement it when they roll out their
online paid services or perhaps they
just want us to never let go of our
switch ever that's pretty smart actually
and lastly we have the one feature that
we all know is coming someday we just
don't know when the Virtual Console or
whenever they end up calling it I mean
technically they didn't miss the mark if
they never aim to hit it
okay that's being a little bit unfair
since Nintendo did promise that we'll
have classic games available to download
whenever their online service comes out
but according to their website that
won't be going live until September of
this year and that's what eighteen
months since launch even though we you
received nes games less than three
months into its lifespan
come on Nintendo just give us our
downloadable GameCube games and we'll
give you all the money in the world deal
it's no doubting Nintendo has a massive
success on their hands with the switch
and although these feel more like minor
grievances then huge glaring issues
Nintendo could still make the effort to
improve the console even more things
like game folders customisable
wallpapers media players these shop
improvements these all might seem like
simple quality of life changes but they
certainly add up and would make using
the switch and even more enjoyable
experience
Nintendo has some great momentum going
into its second year and if they can
patch all these holes in their boat
they'll be sailing strong for years to
come so how about you guys have you
enjoyed the switches for us here is
there anything that you'd like to see
added or fixed or implemented later on
leave them in the comments below and
don't forget to visit GameSpot comm all
weekend long for more coverage on the
switches 1st anniversary
my name is Joey and thanks for watching
[Music]